My name is Colin
Gillespie, and I'm
going to be talking about
comparing package versions.
I worked for jumping
rivers, essentially,
this slide can be summarized
as "we do everything
with R and Python
if you need help with that".
If you've been
around the exhibit
stands, we also do a smashing
side project on coasters.
And do you know how hard it is to get
500 coasters through US customs?
It's surprisingly
difficult, even when
you say you're going to
an RStudio conference.
You just think that
should explain it all.
So if you want to
have that story,
come and have a chat as well.
So we all love R.
You start your project,
you pull in wonderful packages,
you do some amazing code,
and then you're about
to present your results and
you think "I could just
update my packages?"
What is the worst
that could happen?
Surely, well, not a
lot could have changed
where we've all been there.
And you've gone from praising
the R gods to swearing at them
and cursing them and
hating everything about it.
And essentially
what the question
is when a package is updated.
How do you find
out what's changed?
So it should be
an easy question.
How do you find out what's changed?
Well, if the gods are smiling
in your favor and the package
author has been wonderful.
So here is lubridate.
You can see you've
got a nice news file.
My news files are not like this.
I wish they were, but you
can sort of see it's nice.
Links to issues, new
features, bug fixes.
It's all very good, it's great,
you know, you clickable links,
it tells you exactly
what's going on.
They may even be
a blogpost
by the authors detailing
exactly what's changed.
And you could walk
out and that's good.
So that's if you're lucky,
the birds are singing,
the sun shining.
If you're unlucky.
Well you may have to
go to the git repo.
This is lubridate's git
repo. But just trying
to keep the consistent so.
And that's not bad, right?
You know, in the grand
scheme of things,
going through someone's
git repo is definitely
better than nothing.
And it's OK.
You may just be relying on
something like R Weekly,
for example, to help you
figure out what's going on.
And that could be another
way of figuring out.
And if you've done something
to upset essentially everyone,
then essentially download
the tar.qz file from CRAN
and you try to sit there
and you try and work your way
through.
And these people
here are essentially
showing fake consultant
happiness. So fake consultant
happiness and may mean
this when your client asks
you to do something you really
don't want to answer, you just
go, "Yes, that's fine.
Of course I'll do that."
So if you've ever gone
through the source code,
It's not a fun process because
you're trying to figure it out.
And this is where I diffify came in.
So this is diffify.com.
And essentially
it's trying to make
that package difference easier.
So you go to diffify.com,
you click on R,
and then you put in your package
that you want. This a team
effort.
So it's really about 10
contributors and all of them
done amazing job at coding
with the exception of me, who is
standing here presenting, has
done no coding whatsoever.
So I'm loving the dream of
not doing any of the real work
but standing presenting it.
So thank you to
all the other nine
people who have done the work.
So as an example, I thought,
well, we go for lubridate,
so you type in lubridate.
And that's a package.
And then you get to choose which
version you want to compare.
So you've got one.
You're going from two.
We've gone back to
roundabout, think it's 2017,
We're probably going to go...
We'll keep knocking off
a year until things start
breaking in the parsing
and then we'll probably not
go back any further. We reckon
around to 2014, but
just in 2017 is fine.
So here we're going to
compare version 1.8 with 1.79.
The news is mostly
split up, so we can see
that it's been a few releases.
1.792 wasn't actually on
CRAN, but that news file
was kicking about somewhere.
So the news part.
Highlights what's changed to
describe the news. More useful...
You can actually
start exploring what's
changed programmatically.
So, sometimes it's not a news file.
Sometimes the news
file is incomplete.
So here we can see
that rcpp has been
removed as an import from
lubridate over the last version.
We can look at
the namespace file
and again we get
the same idea here.
So we've had four functions
added to the namespace file
in that version change that.
We can have a look.
We can look at the
functions and here we
can see where we've got four
functions added and one of them
has the arguments have changed
and then we can click on that.
And we can see exactly
which arguments
have changed in this function.
So here we can see that the
second positional argument has
changed and that could cause
something seriously bad
to go with your code, right?
So if you're relying on
positional arguments,
that could be a
bit of a problem.
So the roadmap is the
next step is we're
going to have CICD for package steps.
So essentially you're
working on GitHub
and you can automatically put
up your version 0.9000.
And so you can
sort of see what's
happening to dev version.
Python should have been
released last week.
It's now going to be
released next month.
That's life, isn't it?
And essentially we've got a
whole bunch of other things.
But if you've got ideas,
please come up and see or tweet
or email or anything like
that and we're really happy
for suggestions,
happy for questions.
And feel free to go to diffify.com and get
a feel for what's going on.
Thanks.